en directo Vamos hasta chile la cámara
de diputados aprobó una ley que le da
más atribuciones a la policía chilena en
el uso de armas la normativa que se
originó tras la muerte de dos agentes de
la policía ahora pasa al senado y ya
está generando polémica en el país para
ampliar esta noticia saludamos en
Santiago a Leo honores Leo bienvenido
qué es lo que dice exactamente esta ley
cuéntenos
Hola buenas noches el concepto que está
generando la mayor de discusión aquí en
Chile es el de la legítima defensa
privilegiada que permite justamente a
carabineros el uso del arma de fuego
ante el riesgo de su integridad física
Es algo que genera gran discusión porque
hay algunos expertos en seguridad y
también en derechos humanos que han
planteado que este podría ser la puerta
de ingreso al fenómeno del gatillo fácil
y esto se ha instalado como una
discusión bastante intensa en el
congreso de todas maneras fue aprobado
con una amplia mayoría Durante esta
jornada en esta tarde específicamente y
pasa ahora al senado ese parte de
dieciséis proyectos que se pretenden
discutir y aprobar dentro de los
próximos tres meses es una agenda
bastante intensa muy cargada desde un
punto de vista de la seguridad
específicamente y esto se ha acelerado
mucho por hechos recientes no solamente
por la muerte de los carabineros naín y
retamal cuyos apellidos marcan estas
leyes que se están discutiendo sino que
también por la muerte de una Sargento
segundo Durante este fin de semana nada
más quien fue validada en la cabeza de
parte del gobierno se ha planteado que
se van a presentar indicaciones para
evitar de que estas normativas Por
ejemplo permitan o que abran la puerta a
excesos está muy reciente y muy fresco
El Recuerdo aquí en Chile respecto de lo
que ocurrió en el estallido social con
denuncias de violaciones a los derechos
humanos y el caso de cuatrocientas
personas que perdieron la visión
producto de disparos de perdigones de la
policía es justamente uno de los temas
que ha planteado digamos el debate y que
ha generado mayor discusión y mayor
tensión en el congreso de todas maneras
se ha planteado que es muy probable que
todas estas iniciativas estas 16
proyectos de ley sean aprobados en las
próximas semanas en un plazo máximo de
tres meses que se ha dado para poder
resolver todo este tema así que es una
discusión que está muy muy intensa aquí
en nuestro país principalmente porque
las facultades en este caso para
carabineros que son mayores facultades
también
exigen han dicho los expertos que hay
una mayor preparación y es allí en donde
se quiere poner un punto específicamente
para evitar de que se produzcan excesos
es el principal aspecto de preocupación
y de discusión en el día de hoy aquí en
Chile Leo la jornada de hoy también
estuvo marcada por protestas cuéntenos
porque se originaron estas nuevas
movilizaciones muy brevemente por favor
muy brevemente Así es son eh
manifestaciones en el marco del día del
joven combatiente se han registrado
durante todo el día principalmente
marcada por estudiantes y ahora en la
noche con cortes de caminos y barcadas
esto Recuerda la muerte de 12 militantes
de izquierda en la dictadura en 1985 que
fueron asesinados por la policía y año
tras año se genera disturbios en esta
fecha y este año en particular es
especial Porque se cumplen 50 años del
golpe de estado aquí en Chile